you
the sun is shining and it's a hot and
humid 33 degrees Celsius in the shade
heat is an opponent as powerful as rain
cold headwinds and steep climbs
I am on my way to the finish line and
stress is not getting less because time
is getting short therefore I am scooting
through the early night to make it in 80
days and that is quite tricky
because it's hard to find your way in
the dark
in the past seventy nine days I've
traveled a hefty 2457 kilometers and
I've arrived in missin bill homs in the
state of bavaria tomorrow i have to
reach the southern tip of germany it's
going to be tight
missing Balaam's is very idyllic but you
have to wonder what could be so special
about it but of course there is
something the smallest mobile private
brewery in the world it has been
registered in the Guinness Book of
Records since 1996
and this is what it looks like it's
really small relatively manageable and
can even brew 50 liters of beer at a
time etag lhasa made it how can you brew
beer with such small equipment
especially as breweries are usually huge
as a discounts ish in fact it's all
reduced and scale to produce 50 liters
per brewing and it's fully operational
buffoon can you explain beer brewing in
simple terms let me love you we have the
raw materials water malt and hops I
release the sugar from the malt and
later it ferments the yeast to alcohol
and carbon dioxide okay I think I can do
that and I get to work the basics needed
a water mold and hops off we go first I
combine marlton water for the mash the
next process is called Lau during it's a
bit like pouring coffee and in doing it
the husks of the malt kernels are
filtered out leaving what's known as the
wort afterwards the hops are added with
the aid of yeast the beer ferments at
eight degrees Celsius after four weeks
of storage at zero Celsius the beer can
be drunk
and when it comes to brewing beer the
Germans are among the frontrunners there
are more than 1,200 breweries here a
third of the world's breweries are in
Germany Germans drink an annual 107
liters of beer per capita and can choose
from among about 5,000 German beers but
Germans favorite drink is actually
coffee at 151 liters per capita per year
mineral water takes second place at 140
liters and then comes soft drinks at 120
beer only makes it to fourth place and
it gets worse why of the Everett's
German has drank 160 litres of beer in
2004 this has dropped to one hundred and
seven point two liters by 2011 some beer
consumption in Germany is slightly
receding but inquire Germans drinking
less beer this in the bar [ __ ] there are
a few factors first there's the alcohol
limit for drivers another factor is that
entertaining at home has more status
people meet less often in the pub I'm
touche Vanveen eager mm-hmm
that calls for a drink after more than
twenty four hundred kilometers on a
scooter I think I deserve a beer bottoms
up I continued my scooter marathon in
pretty high spirits onwards to the south
aiming for the Alps I can't believe I'll
soon be there
you